my name is alexandr serebryanika, i’m from mariupol, it’s a Donetsk region in eastern ukraine, i’m doing business we have several family businesses here in Kyiv, my close friend and I defended the maidan during the assault on February 18, 19 at night when there was an assault with military weapons when the first mass deaths began near me the guy died killed him I tried to give him first aid I realized that he was not breathing and he had no pulse, they handed him over to the doctors and I turned back looked at the barricades everything was burning there something exploded two days later I saw a photo of this guy whom I was carrying his family was looking for him on facebook I contacted his wife I was the first to call I told what happened and at that moment I realized that I was so scared that I had never experienced such fear in my life to return to the hot barricade it was obvious but tell the woman that her my husband died and it is not known even in his body was found it was very scary and she sent me an sms two days later save
because thanks to
you we found him in the heavenly hundred in this
Areopagus the heroes of the martyrs who died for the
freedom of the country he is a programmer from
Kramatorsk, Donetsk region in eastern
Ukraine